what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
all right so we are stepping back into
the Incredible Hulk and in the last
video we had talked about how the
identity of the Red Hulk had been
revealed as general Thunderbolt Ross now
again most everybody who decided to you
know not wait because I'd kind of drug
this out in the videos and I imagine a
lot of people were just like we know
what I'll just go to the Marvel wiki and
I'll find out who Red Hulk is people
heat knew that for quite some time in
fact the revelation of the red hulks
identity was big news because it took so
long to reveal it but once people had
learned that it was general Thunderbolt
Ross some people like this some people
felt a little underwhelmed but what we
get in this story is basically how it is
that general Thunderbolt Ross became the
Red Hulk so again we had talked about
this off and on and since I dropped a
few mentions here and there but one of
the other big things that I wanted to
address in this video and the question
that people had is if general
Thunderbolt Ross was killed by the Red
Hulk then who was general Thunderbolt
Ross who did the Red Hulk he'll if the
Red Hulk is general Thunderbolt Ross how
does all that work well the cool thing
about this is that this this particular
comic is actually split into two parts
that in truth we only really need to pay
attention to the second half because the
first half just really talks about how
general Thunderbolt Ross was defeated by
Bruce Banner over and over again it
doesn't really matter that much it does
count talks about why he has such a
hatred for banner I mean that's really
kind of self-explanatory right I mean
when people think of like the
arch-nemesis of the Incredible Hulk it's
the general Thunderbolt Ross so he needs
a guy that's been tracking him down
almost non-stop you know since he first
transformed into the Hulk but what this
also does is this wraps back around into
the events before civil war and what I
mean by that is general Thunderbolt Ross
had always been sitting in the shadows
he had always kind of been chasing The
Incredible Hulk
but he always been sitting in the
shadows of what he tells us is that the
death of Betty Ross at the hands of
abomination again with abomination
realizing that Betty Ross had basically
a contracted cancer dude were constant
exposure to the gamma radiation by the
Incredible Hulk and then fast-tracking
that cancer to the point that he
basically killed her it left general
Thunderbolt Ross in a state of absolute
anxiety and mourning and so his his
grief led him to go on what was a what
was tantamount to moreso of a crusade
against the Incredible Hulk than he had
ever really pursued him before the
problem with this was that around the
time that Betty Ross died The Incredible
Hulk was jettisoned into space by the
Illuminati which initiated the Planet
Hulk event and so what this did is this
came back and it said here's what was
going on with with with general
Thunderbolt Ross why
the events of Planet Hulk were taking
place there wasn't a whole lot going on
with him ironically enough instead all
that really happened was he was just
kind of watching things unfold when
Captain America died now the reason why
this is important is because general
Thunderbolt Ross had sat back and said
the Captain America was like the one
last true patriot that he was the one
guy that just stood up for what was
right he was the one guy that's had an
asset you know no matter what happens
here's my stance here's what I believe
is important freedom is the most
important thing above all else and
because of this you know in in the eyes
of general Thunderbolt Ross Captain
America was a guy that they can all look
up to he was a god that Thunderbolt
Ross's grandfather and father could look
up to you and the legacy continued and
and that's kind of way it is a marvel
comic's right I mean we Captain America
sistiana we talked about this during
civil war too when Captain America sits
down you know he'll listen to all the
other sides and he'll say this is the
direction things that things are going
in and for the most part Captain
America's word is law
like superheroes will say okay fine he's
like the Superman of the Marvel Universe
not in terms of power but in terms of
the authority and the respect that he
commands and so because of this you know
with Captain America essentially being
assassinated with the Incredible Hulk
thrown off planet general Thunderbolt
Ross felt like he didn't really have a
purpose but in the face of all this he
saw himself as a patriot he said fine if
Captain America's dead then what we need
is a true patriotic hero we needed
someone to basically step up and take
his place now this was not something
that he initially welcomed and said he
really just kind of fell into a drunken
stupor where he was just going to bars
all the time but eventually he was
caught up to you by the Intelligencia
now again the intelligencia of the
leader MODOK all these different
villains II these smartest villains in
the Marvel Universe
they were campaigning for world
domination but general Thunderbolt Ross
is vendetta against the Incredible Hulk
would allow them to achieve their goal
and the reason why is because they
basically said we know the Incredible
Hulk is coming back you know the
Incredible Hulk is coming back it's only
a matter of time and when he does we
have a contingency plan in place to
basically take the gamma radiation from
him give it to you and then initiate
what you considered to be making America
great again and so because of this you
know general Thunderbolt Ross was not
initially on board because again
pursuing the Incredible Hulk the way he
does is really more of like a moral
argument in the sense of the Incredible
Hulk represents violence represents
destruction you know he represents an
absence of law and order general
Thunderbolt Ross stands for law and
order and so to ally himself with
villains seemed like something that he
couldn't really bring himself to do but
this all changed when world breaker Hulk
showed up and decided
wrecking everything in Manhattan and so
because of this general Thunderbolt Ross
said okay fine that's what we need we
need somebody who can one stand up to
the Incredible Hulk into can usher in
this patriotic America this return to
law and order because keep in mind in
the post-civil war landscape of Marvel
Comics the earth was chaotic I mean it
was insane I mean you like Captain
America was dead so there went like the
cohesive you know leadership of the
Marvel Universe the lynchpin had
basically just been pulled out and
because of that everything sort of fell
to the wayside The Avengers were just in
disarray the x-men were reduced to 198
people dan humans were out in left field
doing their own thing governments of the
world were losing a mana me was it was
pandemonium on almost every single scale
and so what happened was again like we
had talked about before when Tony Stark
had these satellites that were designed
for the purpose of blasting Bruce Banner
with so much cosmic energy or so much
energy that who basically reduced him
down to his normal form the intelligence
he had basically hacked into the
satellites and so they continued to have
the same end result but the method in
which it was achieved is different Wow
Tony Stark and while we as the reader
saw Bruce Banner blasted with these
satellites and returned back to his
human form the idea was well I mean you
know they just hit him with so much
energy that is you know it basically hit
the reset button on the whole persona
and it couldn't maintain itself anymore
in reality and what had happened is the
intelligence yet had just drained all
the gamma radiation out of him is
basically what they did and so you know
immediately after that happened at gamma
base as it was referred to they took
that gamma radiation and they put it
into general Thunderbolt Ross and he
emerged as the Red Hulk now the funny
thing about this was a general
Thunderbolt Ross sat down and said this
is incredible but it's incredible to be
a Hulk because keep in mind he's not a
mindless beast he's not some brainless
running around just hearing things
up instead he's a thinking feeling and
poking because of this he's got strategy
he has intelligence and so he basically
has all the benefits of the Incredible
Hulk with none of the drawbacks so the
biggest issue with this though is that
again Red Hulk does not have unlimited
strike that's the one thing that the
incredible cast that no one else has the
other half of this was that general
Thunderbolt Ross that basically he was
caught up in the moment that win when
Bruce Banner returned you know when he
was the Red Hulk and Bruce Banner came
back you know he basically went against
him he said I have to be the one to take
out the Incredible Hulk because this
Vendetta had basically overridden any of
his other goals that he had as he was
working alongside the intelligence yet
now because of this in the session of
the Red Hawks story when he we had
basically seen him defeated
and we saw general Thunderbolt Ross
approached him and say we gave you
everything that you needed to succeed
and you still failed us what we're told
is that that was a life model decoy that
the general Thunderbolt Ross that that
that Red Hawk killed was a life model
decoy not only that that general
Thunderbolt Ross LMD was killed due to a
plan that was formed by Red Hulk and
Bruce Banner and the reason for this is
because people only know what they're
shown unless they know what goes on
behind closed doors they have no real
idea what's taking place and so what had
happened was ruse Banner and Red Hulk
got together and said general
Thunderbolt Ross has to die and so they
basically had general Thunderbolt Ross
to LMD
jump into a suit of armor go against Red
Hulk Red Hulk killed it and to everybody
who looked at the situation all they saw
was that general Thunderbolt Ross had
been killed by Red Hulk and so what it
did is it steered any suspicion away
that the Red Hulk was general
Thunderbolt Ross now what this did is
also allowed Ross to basically go on a
campaign to again you know basically
take his fight to the unintelligent see
rather but what this does is this wraps
back around to the current events of all
the hopes that are running rampant in
the I guess on the surface of the earth
with regard to you know the Avenger
Hulk's and x-men Hawks as someone so
forth but it also shows us that general
Thunderbolt Ross is is still in the oval
office he's more or less taken over
command he's orchestrated what amounts
to a coup d'etat because that was the
goal of the intelligentsia was to put
one of their own men inside and to
basically take over the country the
issues that the Red Hulk destroys all
this when he rips off the head of
general Talbot and reveals it's habit is
actually a life model decoy and so
everyone seems to be a life model decoy
in here now at this point we get into
the return of world breaker Hulk because
this was damage that this was a badass
moment so wanted to keep in mind here is
that the bombarding of gamma radiation
on to these different people these
different you know individuals didn't
mean that everybody turned in the Hawks
and the traditional sense most of them
did but that was because of the fact
that they weren't wildly intelligent and
that was really just you know Jeff flow
and Greg package saying hey you know
these guys aren't dumb but they're
certainly not on the level of like Bruce
Banner and Amadeus Cho and so on and so
forth something else that I also want
you to keep in mind too is that Bruce
Banner constantly mentioned when he was
being monitored by the inteligencia that
Amadeus Cho was never in the top eight
smartest beings on the face of the
planet
this was actually revealed to be a ruse
now the way this initially picks up is
Bruce Banner still pissed off at a son
because keep in mind Skaar had basically
stabbed she hooked through the back in
order to protect his father but Skaar
didn't know
and Boehner didn't know that that red
she-hulk was actually Betty Ross and so
because of this you know Boehner is
still still lashing out not only that he
tells Betty look you have to turn back
into into red she-hulk you have to go
back into Reggie Hulk that way your
healing factor will kick in you'll
survive and then you can you know live
your life or do whatever you need to do
but she says no and the reason why is
because when she's red she Hulk she's
not a normal human being she's not like
general Thunderbolt Ross where she you
know has her own intelligence and so on
and so forth she does but what she tells
us is that when she was initially killed
by abomination and when her body was put
on ice by her father and in the
inteligencia took her body and subjected
her to gamma radiation and created red
she-hulk they also modified her brain so
that she was just mad all the time she
was basically just filled with rage and
Nasr qualms here is she turns back into
red she-hulk she'll just be raging all
the time just that's it all she'll want
to do is destroy things and so the idea
is that initially you know she says hey
look I'd rather die as Betty Ross then
live as red she-hulk but of course doc
Samson shows up and says hey look man
like yeah she's red she-hulk you know
and and yeah she looks different than
you but in the end her her core is still
the same if you make her angry she will
become a Hulk and so he says just make
her mad just make her is angry as you
possibly can and that's exactly what
happens you know it's more or less doc
Samson and Skaar taunting her event and
then she emerges now of course when she
sees doc Samson that's really the straw
that breaks the camel's back well that's
when the Reggie hook persona emerges and
the reason why is because remember doc
Samson's axis machine the machine that
he used to basically siphon off through
Spanish power way back in the day and
make himself doc Samson himself the the
whole kind of power that he does that
was used by the intelligencia to make
all these Hawks to make red she-hulk and
so in red she walks man dr. Samson is
the reason why she is the way she is and
that's one of the reasons why she lashes
out but of course before she kills him
we end up having the arrival of Amadeus
Cho now
Amadeus Cho in Marvel Comics and if I'm
gonna be honest with you guys Greg Pak
was always leading up to Amadeus Cho
becoming the incredible offering what we
see right now with Joe being all-new
all-different hawk it was only a matter
of time before that happen um I actually
had a really really cool opportunity to
talk to Greg Pak at the Kamikaze con in
Los Angeles and one of the things he
said was that as a guy of Korean
American descent he always wanted to see
you know a little bit more diversity in
terms of comics and well diversity is
not a bad thing one of the biggest
issues people
is when you get rid of something
perfectly good for the sake of diversity
and that's one of the reasons why people
don't really dig Amadeus Cho Hulk too
much because they like banner hall it
wouldn't be a problem to have you know
for a Bruce Banner hook to have like a
sidekick you know where he's like
Amadeus Cho you go out and do some hope
stuff and I'll only become the
Incredible Hulk when pops off like
people would be fine with that but
instead we didn't get that it was you
know kick Bruce Banner out kill him in
civil war too and have Amadeus Cho take
its place it's one of the reasons why
those guys who are curious that's one of
the reasons why there's been so much
backlash when it came to Amadeus Cho
Ruby Williams that kind of thing but the
fact remains here that Amadeus chose
mind has been modified in such a way to
where it basically boosted his
intelligence when he was exposed to
gamma rays he looks grotesque as all
hell like he's ugly as sin but but he's
effectively on par with with MODOK and
he has a little bit of reality welding
potential um he's not a guy that can
work reality on a cosmic scale but he
can kind of defy and bend the laws of
physics and the way this comes into play
is once all these minds of McCoy and
Hank Pym and Chava and Reed Richards are
so on and so forth once they're all
disconnected from this machine maybe you
begin using what time they have to to
begin you know grabbing resources and
trying to find a way to escape and
defeat the Intelligencia we end up
having MODOK going against Amadeus Cho
and he uses his mental powers to
essentially defy some of the laws of
physics in terms of how people view
reality and to skew it a little bit and
this is when Bruce Banner says hey look
Amadeus Cho was always in the top eight
it was probably hang him to be honest he
wasn't in the top late but Bruce Banner
says you know Amadeus Cho was always one
of the eight smartest people I just led
you to believe he was in and basically
screwed up your plans because you know
he was like if what I suspected was true
that your goal was to array D eight all
these different people with gamma
radiation and turn them into Hawks it
would have been better to have someone
who would have been super smart on my
side then to have people who were just
wildly strong and so on and so forth
because again you know it's brains over
brawn so because of this these guys Reed
Richards T'Challa so on and so forth
they come to the realization that the
only way to really solve everything in
order to 2d power all these hooked out
heroes essentially is to use the
cathexis machine to draw all the gamma
radiation out of them the question is
where is that gamma radiation going to
go because you got to keep in mind this
is the gamma radiation from world
breaker Hulk there's a lot of it there
there's there's quite a lot of gamma
radiation there and so what happens is
Bruce Banner steps up and says this was
always the plan the plan was to always
break in here basically to draw
energy back into himself whatever it
isn't it happened to have been
distributed to you know and allow the
whole persona to emerge the issue was
that banner was kind of relying on the
idea that he could keep the Incredible
Hulk contained but to a degree this
makes sense to write because I mean the
Incredible Hulk and Bruce Banner are one
in the same and even if Hulk hates
Banner and banner hates Hulk the two of
them are best suited for one another
they've basically been party to the lies
for so long it's better to have the
Incredible Hulk become part of banner
then have the incredible health become
part of somebody else at least foot in
this point in the story that's so that's
exactly what Banner does he basically
starts pulling all this gamma radiation
out of everybody including dr. Samson
himself and one of the coolest moments
in this story when at one of the coolest
things is when the whole persona begins
to emerge he said we just says gentlemen
run because things are getting ready to
pop off that's what happens it's just
this massive shockwave that reaches all
the way up to Maryland it reaches of New
York City it reaches to Connecticut I
mean the entire North East Coast of the
United States shakes and when the smoke
clears and is all said and done we get
the return of world breaker Hulk not
only do we get the return of world
Wicker Hulk in the next video we're
gonna see scar son of Hulk fighting
world breaker Hulk yes and that's
actually gonna bring an end to the world
war hulk story once we once you do that
video that video will wrap everything up
but um anything guys if you are new here
to comics explained and you guys enjoyed
this make sure you guys hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
robb cork you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah this
is this is actually really fun I love I
love doing the Incredible Hulk because I
always felt like the Jeph Loeb Greg pack
Incredible Hulk stories were like the
Jeff John's Green Lantern stories right
you know where they literally came back
through and just made the Hulk
interesting they reinvigorated all this
interest in the Incredible Hulk mythos
where you know Jeff Jones reinvigorated
all the interest and the Green Lantern
mythos and so it's really cool to see
all this kind of stuff but in any event
yeah I guess I'll catch you guys later
peace